weren't y'all the women's dream team
right that's sometimes the part that
gets sketchy because here we are for our
country but we don't really get the
recognition in our country we don't get
the support our games obviously speak
for itself so we went 58-0
we played in russia we played in china
cuba we played in slovakia we play you
you name it
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today
lisa leslie
hey i'm so happy to be here how's your
uh pool game mine's nice how's yours i
mean it's all good it's subjective
where's where's that little chocolate
she about to hustle the hell
i'm actually a lefty you know that right
so lisa you are a trailblazer and i
appreciate that of the many things that
you do the most what does it take to be
a trailblazer as a black woman in this
country it really is about believing in
yourself learning to love yourself and i
think for me listen i was six foot in
the sixth grade i wore a size 12 shoe
when i was 12 years old now you look
around and you're like damn that is
taller than everybody in this room
taller than most people at home watching
and it was different i was different and
so i think my mom did an amazing job of
really helping me to understand that in
that belief
where did basketball come to fold
basketball i feel like it's my destiny
and that was it i love competition
everybody didn't like to be competitive
and that's okay and i think that part
was really natural for me i love to win
talk about all these ambitions and
dreams you had as a kid playing
basketball but the wnba didn't exist so
how far did you think you could take
basketball once i got to high school it
was there that i realized you can get a
scholarship so that scholarship and me
going to college to play basketball
became the first piece
the second piece was that i wanted to be
an olympian and represent our country
basketball is how i'm going to travel
the world so there is a professional
league you're at usc okay you enter the
olympics weren't y'all the women's dream
team right at the time
appreciate the love
that's sometimes the part that
it gets sketchy because again here we
are for our country
but we don't really get the recognition
in our country we don't get to support
the way that we would hope so we went
58-0
58-0 we played in russia we played in
china
cuba we played in slovakia we played you
you name it
we played everywhere and beat everybody
and it's tough because
america is not recognizing any of that
you know nobody sees that nobody knows
about these trips but it wasn't amazing
the media that you've seen in barcelona
for the 92 team it's not there what how
did y'all how did you handle that they
formed the us olympic team in 1995 they
created a usa national program where we
12 of us traveled the world together for
the whole year playing everybody in
their country it was an amazing time in
our lives we would never trade
any of that any of our teammates for
that experience representing usa wearing
that red white and blue
and kicking butt so having our american
flag raised and hearing our anthem on
podium after podium and having gold
medals placed around my neck that's the
highlight of my career because that was
always my ultimate goal and i made it is
it my turn yeah yeah i like to beat you
you really trying to beat me right now
oh
always
so the gap between the olympics and the
exception of wnba what are you doing in
that meantime so i was in new york when
i get the call so that's within that one
year right 96 i'm i'm out i'm gone
and then we get the call about the wnba
and they're like oh it's going to be in
the summer so i'm like okay cool it'll
be like a summer league right like we
wear reversible jerseys we probably play
like long beach day i don't know by the
time it was all put together we played
at the great western los angeles forum
where the los angeles lakers play so
like my life here in kareem blocker is
the same locker and i'm like dude
i was not ready you know i really wasn't
you're all aggressive with it too
i should have hit my heart
i was probably seven or eight at the
time and i remember the week got next
commercials see what i'm saying what do
you remember from that shoot with spike
lee now spike was awesome because you
know he's an avid basketball fan and
he's he's new york
poor knicks spike is one of those guys
who was like we got to tell this story
because this is really what it is put
together give me your best which was
myself
cheryl swoops dawn staley they had men
lined up because they want to be in a
commercial but they're ballers around
the cage so they broke them up in four
teams
so there was a guard you know forward
and a center and we played these men
just like the commercial said all day
three on three screening shooting
buckets blocking shots really playing
these guys and they filmed all day and
like the commercial says basketball is
basketball we didn't win every game and
i will say to this day we only lost one
game so he says in the commercial they
didn't win every game but they won
enough to save basketball as basketball
and so that's where the yo we got next
that was in my line
here get in there
just be more aggressive it almost feels
like for black women in the league you
got to be an athlete and like a model or
an athlete and an activist and it's
difficult to just market yourself as a
black woman that's really really good at
the sport do you see some discrepancies
there in terms of how white women in
wnba and how black women in wnba are
marketed this is really being kind of
deep but when you think about it we
watch television and we love white
people because we watch shows and we
watch shows for many years
where we have characters that we love
because we like oh i like cindy brady i
like these people and i don't look at
them based on because she's a white girl
and i'm a black girl i identify with
things she's talking about things that's
going on with her family or you know
maybe what she's wearing right
so i don't think we've had that reverse
where a lot of white people have had the
opportunity to
see black people in a way where you
would like love and admire them other
than seeing them in sports i love how
you said it too there's so many of us
doing great things on an everyday basis
absolutely that should be reflected that
people can find some level of
commonality absolutely
there it is
so lisa let's see what you can do on the
papa shout out okay i got 60 seconds let
me ask you some questions see what you
do cool let's do it let's get it three
two one the one athlete that are alive
you want to play
muhammad ali
who are you listening to before a game
tupac
funniest teammate you've ever had
felicia milner
what's your signature
depending on where the defense
off the is
dirtiest opponent you've ever faced
past your buyers man my teammate she
basically became my teammate
is it hot dog or a sandwich a sandwich
favorite pair of kicks you own anything
by george eight seconds gold medal wnba
championship oh man always a gold medal
always come on who's the greatest wnba
player ever ever
including myself i gotta vote for myself
i got 96 by the way you better say
yourself
thank you for coming to pool hall it's
great to have a legend in the building
appreciate you thanks for having me this
was fun
[Music]